these are the people that put their
pronouns in their bio and before they
had that they the Ukraine flag in their
bio and before they had that they had
their vax pass or their their vax card
in their bio and before they had that
they had their mask in their bio let me
show how virtuous of a lemming I am to
the spirit of the age to the state that
level of zealotry isn't going to let you
walk away they're here to fix you
they're here to fix you and if you don't
think you need to be fixed you will be
made to care and the only reason the
tanks aren't rolling yet is because you
all own about 400 million guns if you
didn't the tanks would be rolling
already well they're working on that
part yeah and so they're not going to
let she's right when she says that but
any society that really needs that would
not be able to accomplish it either
because the divisions that exist once
not both sides are not going to agree to
peaceably walk away